titel von diesem videos kein klick
bättig will die mit geld verdient werden
ausgeschaltet ich will hier mit nicht
möglichst viele klicks machen meine
reichweite steigern oder um gottes
willen mitleid bekommen es geht mir nur
darum dass ich in diesem video eine
story über die krankheit die ich seit
acht monaten mittlerweile habe und die
einfach nicht weg geht die story einfach
öffentlich machen bald ein großer
bestandteil von meinem leben ist und
youtube auch ein großer bestand von
meinem leben deswegen will ich auch
wissen dass ihr euch das video bitte bis
zum ende anschaut und wenn ihre freunde
habt die so etwas ähnliches haben was
ich gerade habe zeigte ihnen gerne video
beide ich hätte mich sehr freuen wenn
ich vor einiger zeit und so ein video
wie das jetzt gerade entdeckt hätte
einfach nicht besser dadurch ein
bisschen zur heilung zu beruhigen bitte
versteht auf diesem video hier nicht
viel schneiden werde ich halt das video
nicht so lustig mache mir meine anderen
videos ansonsten lief der einfachen volk
bin ich auch jetzt gerade und ich
versuche nur ihren zu verbieten
und er eigentlich gar nicht lustig war
jetzt einfach mal an und zwar habe ich
vorhin schon 50 minuten sollen video
hier gemacht und hab dann gedacht komm
ich breche zu lange kein schwein an
deswegen jetzt die kurzfassung ich war
weihnachten mit meiner familie im urlaub
und ich bin zur ruhe gekommen da vor
erreichen der uni unter vorarbeit beim
praktikum an alles mögliche und hatte
täglich immer nur drei bis vier stunden
schlaf pro tag ich war eine zeit lang
jeden tag sport machen ich war jeden tag
im video produzieren nicht jeden tag in
der uni gefühlt aber praktikum mich
verarbeiten und da bleibt keine zeit
mehr übrig um zur ruhe zu kommen das
hochsichere mehrere monate in meinem
leben und dadurch dass ich die ganze
zeit im havel war wirklich hatte ich nie
diesem moment wo ich wirklich
runtergekommen bin und dieser moment ist
eingetreten weihnachten 2006 bin ich war
eine woche mit meinen eltern im
skiurlaub in einem wellnesshotel und wir
waren dort die winterruhe bekommen haben
dort gechillt und ich war auf einer
party haben in dem hotel mit weil wir
haben halt auch freuen und sohn im hotel
und das auch mehr schönenberg abend im
bett und ich wollte einschlafen nach der
partie um alles guten am nächsten tag
bin ich dann halt nicht so gemerkt ok
irgendwie sie schlägt mein herz ein
bisschen schneller
ich versuche mir ein bisschen zu
entspannen haben
eine massage im hotel gebucht abend im
bett und auf einmal gold einschlafen und
auf einmal mein herz dran zu flimmern
mannschaft war so flimmern
es hat sich die ganze zeit so auf und ab
gegangen hat das herz gewinnen wie es
nur von vorne nach hinten
die ganze zeit die ganze zeit das ging
über eine stunde 1 2 stunden konnte
danach nicht wieder einschlafen ich
hatte todesangst für mein herz
explodiert und flächen herzinfarkten
sterben mit 20 an einem herzinfarkt ich
sage meiner schwester im wettstreit ums
hotel zimmer geteilt haben und meine
schwester gesagt hey beruhig dich lueg
ag nach draußen atemluft 1 -klatsche
wasser hin gewicht hat nichts geholfen
gar nichts meine treffer hier wenn du
das detail liegt aber leider nichts
geholfen und ein solcher wieder ein fan
und dachte okay jetzt funktioniert
bestimmen jetzt besser geworden nach
eineinhalb stunden ist wiedergekommen
und dann war's mittlerweile dann nämlich
um drei uhr nachts oder so dann habe ich
auf jeden fall meine mom nacht
aufgeweckt und habe ihr gesagt hätte ich
mich jetzt neben sich im bett halt mal
die hand auf mein herz und sagt mir was
mit meinem herz gerade abgeht und das er
gemacht hat ich habe versucht
einzuschlafen und auf einmal bin hatte
ich ja genau die situation wieder mit
dem herrn von meinem arm sagt nur so hey
dein herz schlägt ein bisschen schneller
aber nicht krass fiel
luca ist es nicht sie losgelassen am
nächsten morgen zum arzt gefahren und er
hat mir in ruhe ekg gemacht hat
blutwerte kontrolliert hat alles mit
meinem erst gemacht habe beim arzt in
österreich wo wir ruhe ekg gemacht haben
dort erlag ich beim arzt und hier wird
mir blut abgenommen blutdruck gemessen
und alles mögliche noch gemacht auf
jeden fall hat der artbildung gesagt hey
luca du hast perfekte werte ich will
mich hier mit meinen blutwerten angeben
oder in zum schreibt aber er hat zu mir
gesagt hey deine werte sind in ordnung
dort kein wunder zu besorgt zu sein
dann habe ich ihm gesagt hey ich gehe
doch nicht zum arzt wenn ich nicht habe
der menschlichen reaktionen der aktion
tier wenn der mensch keine schmerzen hat
dann macht der mensch auch nicht wenn
man mehr doch er
was fehlt wenn es halt meine hand mein
handgelenk gebrochen und im knie da
werde ich bald operiert wegen fußball
noch alte verletzungen wenn man den gips
drum hat oder wenn man merkt okay die
hand ist kaputt ich kann mich bewegen
nicht weiter als so ich habe mich die
zähne putzen ich kann nicht kochen ich
kann nicht duschen nicht locken müller
um die hand machen erst dann merkt man
wie schön das ist gesund zu sein
man geht nicht zum arzt bat köpfe und
das habe ich ihnen dann so klar gemacht
und er meint er kann den schmerz sagt
meine werteten perfekt in ordnung und
als er mir das gesagt hat dass meine
werte in ordnung sind habe ich mir halt
nur gedacht okay mir hat gerade eine art
gesagt ein guter arzt in österreich in
tirol hey deine werte sind perfekt in
ordnung und danach was merkel hat mich
quasi beruhigt und hat mir die anrufe
genommen und hat mir gezeigt ok wird
alles in ordnung und das hat mich dann
ich mal zwei tage später silvester ich
wieder am feiern die ganze zeit party
gemacht
ich bin kein alkoholiker aber ich trinke
alkohol ich stehe auch dazu also es ist
nicht gut ich höre jetzt auf zu trinken
das verspreche ich euch freunde hätte
hätte ich mich auf allen plattformen
wenn ihr sie dass sich alkohol trinke
ich werde natürlich nett machen wo ich
mit freunden unterwegs bin die trink-
oder im club mal eine flasche holen aber
das ist einfach weil man dann spielen
will und ja halt einfach nicht auf den
tanz führer die ganze zeit stehen will
und so die werkreihe wir das bei 15
minuten bin ich habe mir während ich
will das video nicht vorenthalten weil
ich ja vorhin schon ein ganz langes
video aufgenommen haben welche sachen
sagen die ich auf jeden fall euch
mitteilen möchte auf jeden fall kam lag
seitdem als ich schrieb hatte und danach
zur ruhe gekommen bin und bei mir war
immer schon diese bern ort an der sehr
präsent weil ich wie gesagt studiert
habe und nehmen bei youtube gemacht habe
und praktikum gemacht hatte und ich
werde jetzt auch einfach mal öffentlich
machen ich hatte eine freundin von märz
2006 bis januar 2017 und alles da unter
einen hut zu bringen ist einfach mega
schwierig deswegen habe ich letztendlich
mit meiner freundin schluss gemacht weil
nicht primär weil ich nicht mehr
wirklich geliebt habe sondern auch
wirklich wegen der krankheit hat und ich
musste mit vielen sagt man einmal
verabschieden ich bin nicht mehr in die
uni gegangen und habe alles
zu hause gemacht ich habe meine bachelor
gemacht alles gut ist am guten schnitt
auch glaube ich in mir 1,7 oder so
greifen die krankheit dann halt kam habe
ich mit vielen sachen einfach
abgeschlossen
bei insgesamt ok ich muss auf meinem
herzen ich muss auf meinen körper hören
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht was
hattest du denn jetzt genau das ist das
nicht locker wenn ich das auch mal
immerhin habe was kann man dagegen tun
was man die symptome wie sieht man dass
man das schlichtweg eine simple
panikattacke das ist nicht man hat keine
der körper es ist alles in ordnung und
man ist komplett topfit aber man denkt
es nicht man denkt man ist rang und
gedanken können einen kaputt machen ihr
kennt das vielleicht wenn ihr eine
person vermisst oder ihren liebeskummer
oder ihr seid auf klassenfahrt hat
heimweh auf einmal mit behaltet auch
immer fängt man an zu weinen auf einmal
fit hat man auf einmal hat man
allerdings man alles ist scheiße
vielleicht hat der eine mensch erbrechen
zeit hat der andere mensch durch fall
keine ahnung was jetzt eine sache die
man wie stehen und einfach körperliche
reaktionen auf bestimmte zustände weil
ich mal ungenau ist bei einer
panikattacke man denkt okay ich komme
gerade runter alles ist gut und auf
einmal denkt man ok meine atmung wie in
die anders man kann da nichts gegen tun
und da habe ich das die atmung flacher
wird wenn man dementsprechend mehr
sauerstoff ein allerdings auch mehr
kohlendioxid draußen das ist wichtig mit
körper und die sache dadurch dann
einfach dass man glatt wird man kann im
ohnmacht fällt ich bin auch schon so
halten machen in unterbach gefaltet
wegen jetzt setzen die symptome sind
quasi einfach dass man viel schwitzt die
hände zittern die hände kribbeln man
jetzt voll unruhig ich hatte das zum
beispiel kraft auch mein herz hat grad
am schlimmsten ist wirklich eine
komplette ruhe kommt es am tag am
krassesten immer in der situation wenn
man einschläft und da hatte ich auch
immer und die sache wenn eine sache ist
die attacke gab und bei dieser weg so
meint man weiter kämpfer ich hatte panik
attacke aber hey alles cool ich
vielleicht auch für die kinder kennen
dann ist ja alles gut ich habe jetzt
gerade eine panikattacke seit 13 stunden
seit 310 stunden
gebt euch dass der 13 stunden habe ich
herz haben
ich fühle mich schlecht ich habe das
gefühl dass ich sterbe mit panikattacken
hervorrufen durch die atmung also mein
hyperventiliert also man muss die atmung
kontrollieren das merkt ihr vielleicht
bei mir dass sich oft solchen
situationen haben dass sich zu wehr
cristina atmen muss und deswegen werde
ich bald erscheinen
logopäden gehen logopäde genau
kardiologe und zu der ich habe halt
immer nur die linke hat ihr herz für
eine falsch und dann habe ich magnesium
bekommen ich habe tabletten gegen
unruhige wochen bekommen ich habe
betablocker bekommen
locker nicht kentucky von nur drei
genommen ich habe diese acht monaten
warum weil der herr starke medikamente
sind es kann sein dass der körper darauf
reagiert dass man quasi stirbt natürlich
jetzt nicht wo kraft aber das sind sehr
abwehrkraft medikamente und meine mum
und der armee gesagt wir können dir
geben aber sei vorsichtig damit unter
panikattacken also ich kann gar keine
panik aus meinem namen mal im fahrstuhl
stecken geblieben detaillierten dem
plakat und da hatte die dass die
symptome sind bei helfen leuten
unterschiedlich der eine direkte attacke
andere verbrechen und codes direkt in
wohin der andere fällt direkt
internierten herbst und ich denke dass
ich sterben werde auf jeden fall was
mehrheit geholfen hat man keine
medikamente sondern die atmung zu
kontrollieren ist dafür einfach euch
wirklich hinter ich will nicht mit
welche muskeln die nicht mit anzeigen
bis zwei zentimeter unter ihrem
bauchnabel allerhand hinlegen und
dankbar wie einnahmen also ich muss
wirklich atmen tief einatmen ausatmen
ganz lange bis er keine luft mehr hat
und dann einfach sagen wenn ich keine
luft mehr ab jetzt alles in ordnung ist
ein atemzug perfekt hingekriegt
manchmal da macht uns noch mal und noch
mal und noch mal und noch mal und noch
mal im internet stand dass man das ganze
sechs mal machen im internet stand doch
man soll nie tief einatmen das hat bei
mir allerdings nicht funktioniert ich
möchte euch an meine erfahrungen
mitteilen
im internet gelesen habe eine
panikattacke ist klar wie eine an
reaktion des körpers auch ja irgendwas
was man sich einbildet panikattacke wird
doch nicht dadurch hervorgerufen dass
man wirklich gerade in dem moment angst
akut vor irgendwas hat bei mir durch den
von tumoren zurückgefahren mit freunden
die haben sich schön im auto wir sind
zwei stunden gefahren und die
panikattacke kann einfach so rennt
einfach so ist nicht passiert wären
einfach chillen entspannt musik gehört
und dann kam der panikattacke bei mir
bei mir dass ich dann weiß okay das ist
eine panikattacke ich weiß wie ich
dagegen ankämpfen kann ich kann und ich
kann mich auch konzentrierte sind nicht
dass sich die rektorin und zur hilfe
schreien umlauf ich mache eigentlich
relativ ruhig aber auf jeden fall ist
die halt heute wieder aufgetreten und 13
stunden ich weggegangen wirklich ersten
wo ich mir gerade wer jetzt noch eine
neue taktik ich habe eine papiertüte
genau und wirklich einfach die
plastiktüte
was man jedes klargemacht dass man sich
auf die atmung konzentriert und das
kohlendioxid was man aus atmet in den
beutel bzw
plastiktüte oder hier in köln flugzeug
rein fuß wird und dann geeignet damit
man es nicht nach außen frau stößt das
hat mir geholfen gängige methode hält
mit dem aufnahmen dass man die hand hat
unter den bauch name liegt und dass man
mit dem körper redet dass man wirklich
den eigenen körper sagt laut aussprechen
wir wahl aussprechen hediger oder als
gabe die wir haben alle tests gemacht
mit verschiedenen ersten in tirol in
österreich sport erst in köln die besten
kardiologen in köln wieder fällt erste
die haben wir alle gesagt hey du bist du
bist du hast perfekte werte mit ihr
reden nichts passieren es hört nichts zu
tun man kann auch einfach daran denken
und seinem körper rheiner politik heraus
denn bei mir allerdings dass ich mit
meinem körper reden muss das sich ihnen
dadurch beruhigen
das hörte man diese ganze sache das ist
keine krankheit von wegen etlicher diese
angst gut diese trauer wenn man einen
menschen verliert der einsätze die
bedeutet hat man in dem moment hat diese
depressionen die dann auftreten und man
denkt sich auf die stärken dieser angst
des tkc 0,001 prozent von der an die ich
in der nacht hatte moment herzogenrath
hat nur um euch wirklich zeigen das ist
nicht wahr ich ertrage okay ich habe
gerade keine video idee ich will darüber
geschrieben ich habe acht monaten
überlegt ob ich überhaupt oberrieden
soll ich habe in diesem video mitgeteilt
dass ich ein jahr lang war sie eine
freundin hatte das komplett
herausgehalten habe auf youtube es ist
möglich man kann die vorteile man kann
auch den freund aushalten der youtuber
regime ist da nicht jedem glauben der
immer sagt es geht einfach nicht man
muss videos machen und blabla ich hatte
doch ausgerechnet ich war ein jahr zu
finanzieren und der hauptgrund warum
schluss war's einfach wirklich wegen der
krankheit das wird mir wahrscheinlich
keiner glauben habe ich wollte einfach
mit vielen dinge in meinem leben
abschließen die mich mehr gestresst
haben mir gut getan haben und viele erst
da haben wir auch gesagt hat dann gesagt
habe was gefunden ich glaube
panikattacken ich hatte dann haben die
lackiert mit anderen leuten darüber dass
sie daran teilhaben
die müssen sich auch beruhigen das ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm und genau das
der grund warum ich dieses video hier
gerade
ich habe diese karriere gerade für 13
stunden ich bin seit eineinhalb stunden
ja vorhin schon künftigen aufgenommen
die mir jetzt gerade wieder eine halbe
stunde auf macher dieses video hier
wirklich nur um mich zu beruhigen und um
euch zu beruhigen und um die leute zu
beruhigen dieser farben und fällt ihr
das nicht habt dann bitte jetzt wieder
zu reagieren habt wenn ihr doch mal
haben sollte weil jeder mensch also was
früher oder später mal einige heftige
anhalt nicht so heftig über mir heftig
ich hoffe einfach effektiver video
gefallen hat ich werde jetzt auf jeden
fall definiert meiner ernährung
umstellen
es kommt nicht nur nicht den alkohol ich
bin kein alkoholiker ich bin ganz
normaler zu wenig trinkt vielleicht alle
drei vier wochen mal alkohol oder so ich
rauche aber auch nicht ich ernähre mich
eigentlich ganz auf den alkohol ab und
zu als wirklich tun ja auch wenn ich
relativ sportlich jetzt mal als ich
versuche mich zumindest ordentlich auch
zu ernähren und sport und sport leben zu
führen und sich heute dieses video auf
jeden fall nur machen weil wir von
vielen leuten gesagt wurde herr rede
darüber und treten die ganz einfach nur
rum und alles mögliche freunde kraft auf
euer leben auf pump eure gesundheit auch
ich zum beispiel bin gläubig und bete
jeden tag dafür dass meine familie meine
freunde und ich einfach gesund bleiben
dass das einzige kann keiner sagen
schreib ich habe eine karte geschrieben
schreibe ich hab hier eigentlich nicht
ich bin jetzt nicht mehr der beziehung
das wichtigste kongress
damit möchte das video hier beenden ich
will kein auto machen ich habe keine
werbung geschaltet schreibt mir bitte
eure meinung dazu die kommentare
vielleicht handy gerade auch medizin
studiert wenn euer vater ihre mutter
arzt ärztin es gerne mal den sagen was
man vielleicht noch machen kann wird
mich mega freuen und jahren freunde von
euch zulauf haben sollten ältere sind
denn eure eltern oma opa kann um waffen
kann immer auftreten auch bei jüngeren
leuten zeigt innovative video hier bitte
dass die sich keine sorgen machen müssen
und ich bitte meine güte